have you looked back at your life and
said what would have happened if i
hadn't talked to the sci-fi channel
about writing the script
hadn't followed through where would i be
i look back at my life and wish i had
made that independent film
five or ten years earlier
because that's that is kind of what
started the ball rolling
and if i had done that a lot earlier i
think
through one means or another i would
have
uh have you know picked up steam
um along the same path along the same
timeline as i have
but i'd be 10 years younger and
you know and have more energy and have
more um
not optimism that's not the word i'm
looking for because i've got actually
have a lot of optimism right now um now
this is bad for a writer because now i
don't have the word that i need
um i i wish i wish i had done it sooner
um because i think i would be much
further along now
than i am
um is it blind confidence you know how
in youth
people think there's no way they can
fail
and it's i envy that you don't overthink
it you just say oh yeah i'm going to be
the next whatever
no because i still think i'm the next
steven spielberg
i still have blind confidence and blind
optimism
um but you know p um
my manager in particular uh keeps saying
look we've got to take this one step at
a time you did sharknado now we build on
that you do something
like it but more bigger
for lack of a better word and then you
take that and you do something else but
you can't move right on to doing
shakespeare
because nobody's going to take the
writer of sharknado seriously when he
says he wants to do shakespeare
i don't actually want to do shakespeare
but there are there are serious
uh you know genre films that i want to
make that aren't tongue-in-cheek
and so it frustrates me because i'm
already at the point in my life
where i just want to be doing what i do
um you know and i feel like i've paid my
dues and i've been doing this for a very
long time
but but you've gotta you've gotta put
that in check you've gotta
take your ego down a notch you really
have to take your ego out of the
equation
um and say okay this is how
i am perceived by the world and by the
industry
i have to accept that even though that's
not the sum total of who i am
as a person or as a professional i have
to accept that this is the way i'm seen
now
so how do i build on that to get to
where i want to be i completely forgot
what your question was
oh wow that's great sorry i got lost in
what you were saying and i forgot my
question too i think
i i was talking about
resistance and the moment that you
realize
that but it sounds like being paid as a
writer
that does give a professional stamp but
there must have been something very
freeing
in terms of your whole process of going
out and actually doing what you were
saying
doing what you said you were going to do
that that was that
i'm glad you made that said that phrase
because that that's something that i've
that i've realized is that for many
years i had developed a lot of
connections in the business and i was
telling people that i was a good writer
and director
mainly a director to be honest it's it's
a little frustrating for me that
the success and the public perception
that i've achieved as a result of
sharknado and some of the other smaller
things i've done
is largely as a screenwriter because
i've always seen myself as a director
first in a screenwriter second
so that's kind of frustrating but the
the phrase
doing what i said i could do is key
because for years and years i'd been
telling people what i could do if they
would just give me a chance
but that required them taking a leap of
faith on me
and why should they do that when they're
at risk every film
any producer makes every film even a
studio makes
they're risking their entire business
model their entire profession
their entire position in the industry
on every project they make so why on
earth should they take a risk
a leap of faith on me an unproven
quantity
when they can hire steven spielberg or
james cameron or ridley scott or
shane black or whoever that they know is
going to deliver
and of course the argument that the
young filmmaker will make is yes but i
have something new that those guys don't
have
they've been doing this we all know what
they can do
that's legitimate to a certain extent
but not from a business standpoint from
a business standpoint you go with
somebody that you know can deliver
you